Speaker 1: Hey, here's some good news. And
we've been looking for good news lately.
In a new poll, John Fetterman, the Democratic
candidate in Pennsylvania. Senate race is ahead of
Mehmet Oz, the television doctor, by 11 points.
This genuinely is good news. If Oz were able to
defeat Fetterman, it would be a disaster. Now,
there's still some disaster in here, but we'll
talk about that in a second. Democratic candidate
John Fetterman is leading Mehmet Oz by 11 points.
That's a Fox News poll. The poll and remember,
Fox News polls are not particularly bad polls. The
poll released Thursday found Fetterman is backed
by 47% of voters. Oz is backed by 36%. So it's
an 11 point lead now. It's still horrible that
an out-of-state television grifter can get 36%
support. At the same time, I think about 36% of
the country, at least 36% of the country believes
the earth is only 6000 years old. So it's maybe
not that shocking. But the important thing here
is let's not assume that this is over. This is a
critical, absolutely critical Senate race. If you
break down, there's a bunch of different scenarios
that you can outline. But most importantly, if you
say which one race could control of the Senate
hinge on, there's like a handful of such races,
and one of them is the Pennsylvania Senate race.
So if you're from in the state of Pennsylvania,
you must vote. You must vote. We all must
vote. And if you're from outside the state
of Pennsylvania, you're still allowed to phone
bank, you're still allowed to donate or lobby
for donations, fundraise, whatever.
Very, very important race. And again,
we don't we don't concede races just for the hell
of it. But given some obscure race in a extremely
red district for Congress and this Senate race,
when we think about the potential consequences,
this Senate race is pretty, pretty high on the
list. So an important one to get involved in.
We're going to continue covering it. 11 point lead
is good. A lot can happen in the next three months
and it is now only three months until those
midterms. And we'll continue covering this one